i just came back from giving a talk to
my old high school and i asked the
students
whether they thought that they were bad
at maths and basically everyone put up
their hand i mean i expected a fair few
number of hands but not that many which
really sucks because i used to think of
myself as bad at maths when i was in
high school and that really held me back
for ages as well but now i have a phd in
maths i've told this story before on
youtube and one of the questions i get
asked the most is
well did you go back did you go and tell
those teachers who told you you weren't
good at maths that you know
whatever became of you
um well the answer was always no i
didn't feel the need to because i didn't
want to rub it in anyone's face i know
that teaching maths is not an easy thing
and i don't blame those teachers for you
know not believing in me because i i
really wasn't doing well in maths back
in those days
and so it's like i don't know i guess
understandable that they didn't think
anything would come of me but then one
of the teachers who i really like at the
school asked me to come back and give
this talk and i was wondering like what
could i tell these students that would
be helpful to them and i was also
thinking what could i tell these
teachers that would be helpful to them
and
the thing i decided was to talk about
maths and maths ability and how i don't
think that the way that students and
teachers think about math civility is
very healthy and it doesn't lead to good
outcomes for the students but the thing
is when i went there i realized that
most of the teachers who had been a
little bit discouraging had actually
retired and the teachers who were still
there were the ones who were super super
nice to me and had been really really
encouraging and so i decided that i
would make this video in case you are a
math teacher or
a student who's studying maths or a
parent and i hope that maybe some of
this might be helpful to you so i'll
quickly recap my story
when i was in school i thought of myself
as a humanities kid like i really liked
i don't know english and learning
japanese and
history and art and all of those kinds
of things and i didn't think of myself
as like a science person
um until like i was in year 10 or so
which is like 16 years old and i
suddenly discovered physics and realized
like how magical it is i was just amazed
that like with physics you could explain
so much about the world and so i had
this like crazy about face where i went
from thinking of myself as like a
humanity student who is definitely gonna
do something creative and all of that um
to being a like science person like i
was like i'm going to be a scientist but
the problem was i was still really bad
at maths so the way that my school
worked and i think a lot of schools and
at least in australia work is that when
you're 12 or 13 for us
you get a placement test that decides
whether you are good at maths or you're
not
and um what was decided for me was that
i was not i was a pretty mediocre to bad
math student and yet for physics i would
need to do a lot of maths and so i
decided that like okay i'm just gonna
have to do it i'm gonna have to take
like the sort of high level maths
classes um for my final two years and
back in those days people couldn't stop
you if that's what you wanted to do
i learned going back to my school that
actually now it's not possible to do
high-level maths without um needing some
sort of like marks requirements which
yeah i'm glad didn't exist when i was
there because i would not have passed so
anyway when i was deciding that this is
what i wanted to do i asked my math's
teacher do you think that i'll be able
to do it and he thought i was joking and
laughed and walked away he was a nice
guy and i don't blame him for it but he
saw that you know i was struggling even
with like the level of maths that i was
doing and he just didn't believe that i
would be able to pull through and do the
harder stuff and for a while it seemed
like he was right when i was doing the
first year of that high level stuff i
was still kind of struggling and my
teacher for that year told me i should
probably just drop back down to the
standard level in my final year though i
got super lucky and i got this teacher
who convinced me that maths is actually
interesting and i worked really really
hard on maths
with his help and i felt like i was
finally understanding it and i was like
oh maybe i'm a math person after all
that was until i got my final results
for high school maths and i got a five
out of seven which is a very decent mark
but felt like a total failure after i
put in so much work and so when i went
to university i felt discouraged again
and in university you have the option of
doing sort of like um the
like higher level maths track which is
meant for people who want to become
mathematicians and physicists and like
the standard level which was for
everyone else and of course i took the
standard level because i didn't think
that i was made out for it the higher
level track like emphasized um stuff in
pure maths like uh proofs which i didn't
see at all in the standard level and
then in the next year they got to pick
electives that were like analysis and
yeah i didn't take that but exactly
halfway through my undergrad um i
decided to take this course on like
abstract algebra it was just for fun and
i remember distinctly that one of my
friends who had done pure mathematics
was like oh abstract algebra that's not
like a real course it's not as like
hardcore as analysis but yeah i guess
you could do that if you want um i did
and i loved it it made me realize that
maths is actually great like a lot of
the things that i love about physics are
the same things that i loved about maths
it's about understanding how the world
works and like really understanding it
like getting down to the basics um and
also math was just super creative which
i didn't expect at all like from school
i'd kind of expected that maths was this
thing where you just like learn how to
do it and then you follow the rules and
then you get to the right answer but
actual maths isn't like that there's a
whole lot of intuition that goes into
actual maths and that was actually very
similar to in physics and that was
something i really loved about physics
that you had to kind of try and
understand at a very intuitive level and
like feel when an answer is right but
that said i did not do well in that
algebra class because remember at this
point i was well and truly behind
um all these other people had been like
introduced to the idea of what a proof
is
long long ago and i had no idea i
remember very distinctly that
in one of my tutorials they asked us to
prove something for all natural numbers
and i did like 10 examples on an excel
sheet and i printed it out and i gave it
to my tutor and i was like there you go
there's your proof it worked for 10
numbers like surely it's going to keep
working and
i just could not understand why
that wasn't
enough to prove something was true which
is crazy to think about now so like as
you can imagine i didn't do super super
well on that course i did okay um well
but i worked really really hard because
i had to try and learn this like
mathematical mindset of being like more
rigorous and uh that didn't come
naturally to me like at all i think the
creative side of it did come very
naturally and i really love that part
and i took to it very easily but the
part where you had to very very
carefully justify every single thing you
said um using axioms and like very
carefully deriving things from those
axioms was foreign to me it just didn't
occur to me that you had to prove
something was true and rather than just
being like yeah it's obviously true i
feel it i know it's true and so uh yeah
after that semester i was like okay i'm
gonna be a mathematician after all this
but i'm gonna have to pull my socks up
because i have not yet understood this
like mathematical
thinking so what i did was i took walter
rudin which is this very classic
textbook on analysis and i read it cover
to cover did all of the problems over my
summer holidays and it was brutal
it was just like
so painful to deal with all of these
little edge cases and think about you
know being super super careful just just
like not at all the way that i used to
function but after that summer holidays
i feel like i changed a lot and i became
much much more rigorous and i love that
mathematics was this like great balance
between this creative intuitive side and
this very rigorous side i think that
students in high school don't get to see
mathematics like this they only see the
more rigorous but also very formulaic
part of maths where you're basically
just following an algorithm and getting
an answer and it makes less and less
sense that that is the part of maths
that's emphasized in high school when
there are you know great calculators and
like online tools for doing basically
any integral you can think of or any
calculus problem that you can think of
and so it doesn't really make sense to
make students extremely good at those
things what they should be emphasizing
is the kind of mathematical thinking
like both the sort of rigorousness of it
and also the more conceptual side the
other thing that i just wish teachers
understood more and students is that
math is just a skill like any other
skill you have to practice and you have
to work really hard at it and yes some
people are going to pick it up a lot
more quickly and some parts of it are
going to come more naturally to other
people but that doesn't mean that anyone
can't learn this like for me i think
that that sort of creative side came
fairly naturally but the rigorous side
came like pulling teeth i mean it was
hard i put in a lot of work to get
better at those specific things and i i
still know that i'm not like as good as
those bits as i could be and that's fine
when i was doing maths research i did
put a lot of work in to try and make
myself better on the rigorous side
because my supervisor had told me that
that was one of my weaknesses and so i
went and like would reprove things from
papers and try and really do things step
by step and that's just like anything
else is a skill that you have to
practice and you have to learn
and yet the way that schools talk about
maths is as if it's some innate skill
like i cannot believe that
at 12 i was given a test that decided
whether i was good at maths or bad
and that because that test said that i
was bad at maths i was put into a class
where i wasn't shown as many interesting
mathematical ideas and the teachers kind
of came in with the notion that we were
never going to amount to anything in
fact i remember very clearly
how when we were learning the quadratic
equation
we had a substitute teacher who was
usually a teacher who would teach one of
the like proper maths classes and not
our class she was talking about the
determinant under the square root and
she was saying that if the determinant
is positive then there's actually a
solution and if it's negative then
there's no solution
but actually that's not true she said um
there's a complex solution in that case
but you guys won't learn about complex
numbers
i remember feeling so frustrated and
angry about that it just felt so unfair
that you couldn't learn something and
someone had decided that decided that
for you a long time ago
i want to make it clear that i had a lot
of really great science and maths
teachers and if it wasn't for them and
their encouragement i definitely
wouldn't have ended up here
um so yeah i've talked about some like
bad teachers but they weren't the
majority and in that way i was really
lucky so if you are talking to a student
about maths whether that's your own
student or your child or a friend's kid
or whatever it is
i just urge you to like make sure you're
not
reinforcing the idea that you're either
good at maths or you're not
thanks